-Our next guest is a sports
Emmy Award-winning journalist
who hosts "Game Theory
with Bomani Jones."
New episodes premiere Friday
nights on HBO and HBO Max.
Please welcome to the show
Bomani Jones, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rock plays ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Bomani!
I'm so happy to you have here.
-I appreciate it.
You give everybody
the dap hug like that,
or am I special?
-You're special. Yeah.
-Okay, just checking.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I don't know if I gave it
to your sister
when she was here because --
this is very fun --
your sister was the first
in your family
to be on the show.
She's an author.
She wrote an incredible
book called
"An American Marriage."
-Yeah. I have to say,
I was very excited
and proud of myself
until I realized
I was second place
in my own house
[ Laughter ]
on being on this
television show, okay?
-But you do have siblings
who haven't been on the show
as well, right?
-Yeah, I do. I do have
a couple of those, so.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, great. So you can
lord it over them.
-Yeah. Like my brother lives
across the street from me.
I will definitely have
to tell him that,
"You're going to have
to figure something out."
He better start telling some
jokes or dancing or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you have covered sports
for a long time
-Yes.
-in a lot of different
formats --
radio, podcasts, on TV --
but now you got your own show.
And with the world of sports
being as big as it is,
it must be cool
to finally be in a position
to set the agenda every time
you get behind the camera.
-Yeah, like I think when you do
like a radio show
and stuff like that,
you are in charge,
but it's radio, right?
Like people don't take it nearly
as seriously.
It's just a little bit of a zoo
of sorts when you do that.
When you get into television,
it's a zillion different people
that are doing this, doing that.
They got all these different
departments to get into.
And I remember the first day
that we opened the office up
for "Game Theory,"
we had this meeting and people
were presenting the schematics
for some field piece
that we had.
And it dawned on me --
I've never been in a meeting
where everybody cares
about what I think
and they're all staring at me
like so intently,
trying to figure out how I feel
about something.
But it's COVID,
so I got a mask on.
[ Laughter ]
And they just lose it.
Like they just staring
and they're so scared
and I got this like giant smile
on my face the whole way
and they have no idea because
we're trying not to die.
[ Laughter ]
-That was the right thing
to try not to do.
One thing you and I have
in common --
I've obviously been doing this
a long time,
you're new at it,
but one thing we agree on --
we do not care for teleprompter.
-[ Laughs ]
-I've got a cue card guy.
I've been working on cue cards
my whole career.
But how are you finding
the teleprompter?
Are you getting used to it?
-Yeah, man, I went in
and got a teleprompter coach
-Oh, yeah?
-to help me do that
because like I could read
the teleprompter.
It's just really hard
to be yourself
while you're reading
the teleprompter.
Every word that I'd ever said
in public before, really,
was coming
off of the top of my head.
And, now, all of a sudden
we have to write this down
and that feels confining
and everything else.
You know, I've got somebody,
he's an actor and he comes in
and he basically teaches me how
to read again.
[ Laughter ]
-So you feel good?
-I do. I do.
-Alright. I want to ask you
about some of the stuff
in the world
of sports right now.
First off, I mean,
it does feel like maybe this
is the third offseason in a row
where this is going
to be a question.
Tom Brady -- did he come back,
is he going to play
another year?
What do you think?
-I feel like,
if you put your whole family
on the roulette wheel
to go 8-9
and now, that family isn't there
anymore, why not come back
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, interesting.
-and play again, right?
Like, "Sure, I'd love
to go sit in my house by myself
and eat Hungry Man dinners.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Who doesn't want
to do that?"
No, I mean, in fairness to him,
any football player I talked to,
the adjustment
of no longer playing anymore
is really, really
difficult for them.
And people will let Tom Brady
play football
as long as he wants
to play football.
I, personally, would not want
to get hit in the kidneys
at age 46,
but I got different kidneys
than he does.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
There's like less room
between the outside of you
and your kidney.
-There's less room between the
outside of me and my kidneys
than probably anybody else
on planet Earth.
[ Laughter ]
I've made peace with that.
-A cool story has been
Brock Purdy,
last player drafted
in the NFL draft last year.
Mr. Irrelevant is the name
they give to that
and now, he's got --
the San Francisco 49ers
in the championship game.
I feel like you keep waiting
for it to strike midnight
and him to turn back
into, you know,
regular old Cinderella,
but what's going on here?
-I do hope that he has a measure
of perspective about this.
Like you mentioned me being
an Emmy Award winner.
I didn't win an Emmy.
I got an Emmy.
-[ Laughs ]
-I was an executive producer
on a "30 for 30" documentary
and so, when they do that
and it wins
Best Documentary Series,
everybody gets an Emmy.
They would've won an Emmy,
no matter what I had done,
and that makes it better.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I just got it, right?
Like I didn't have to really --
I did something,
but I just got it.
And I hope that Brock Purdy
has the proper perspective
to understand that,
while he is doing his job,
if they win a Super Bowl,
he gonna get one.
Like we don't have to make it
more than it actually is.
We can appreciate that.
"Wow, you showed up
for work late
and, the next thing you know,
everything went well
and you got a win?
Great for you!" right?
[ Laughter ]
But you gonna get that Emmy.
-You had a great piece
about how crypto became
very tied in
with professional sports,
up to and including
the Miami Heat had
an FTX Arena that they were
playing in.
Obviously, they're no longer
playing in an FTX Arena,
due to everything
that happened with FTX.
[ Laughter ]
What was your original --
Obviously, I think you were
very early here in saying,
"Hey, this doesn't quite
smell right.
The whole world of crypto
and how quickly sports
is wanting to have
a partnership with it."
-Well, I had started looking
into it about ten years ago.
There was this website
called Silk Road
that was basically an open air
drug market on the dark web.
But real drug dealers
don't sell drugs on the Web,
so you knew it wasn't
real drug dealers,
but they were making
all their trades with Bitcoin
and then the FBI showed up
and they had all these not
actual drug dealers panicked.
And I was like, "Well, tell me
more about this Bitcoin."
And then I raised the question,
"Why would I trade my money
for money that's not money,"
right?
[ Laughter ]
Like when I go
out of the country,
I take my money
and I trade it for other money.
You're telling me
that I got this money
that works perfectly well
and I'm going to trade this
for some other money
because this other money
might be worth more.
Well, what's going to make the
value of that other money go up?
"I'm going to tweet about it,"
right?
[ Laughter ]
And we're just going
to make the value
of this other money come up.
And that was just like --
I hear about like the digital
dollar and everything
and I've studied economics
pretty decently and I was like,
"My dollar look pretty damn
digital right now."
[ Laughter ]
Like I got --
the money in my pocket
is not all the money I have.
The rest of it is ones
and zeros.
And I just couldn't see
how other people
didn't understand the idea
of turning your real money
into funny money
[ Laughter ]
doesn't add up.
-And you sort of saw this
very clearly
and I should give you credit.
A lot of people didn't.
In the Super Bowl ads
because there were all these
crypto ads last year
in the Super Bowl
and they had
a very different message
than sort of the more classic
financial services companies
that have Super Bowl ads.
-Yeah, no, you see a commercial
for Merrill Lynch
or for Charles Schwab
or any of them other dorks that
[ Laughter ]
get up there and do the trading
and they're always telling you,
[ Baritone ]
"Take care of your future."
It's always very serene
and peaceful.
These crypto ads were like,
"Fortune favors the brave!"
Why do I need to be brave
about my money?
[ Laughter ]
My entire life is about not
being brave about my money.
The whole reason
that you take your money
to somebody to invest it is
because you're not brave!
[ Laughter ]
It is because you are terrified
of a zillion different factors
and the only people
who are trying to be brave
with their money are broke!
[ Laughter ]
So, I understood why,
if you were broke
and somebody tells you
you can turn five into ten,
you'll give it a try.
But, as our good friend
Mr. Madoff showed us,
[ Laughter ]
once you hear about a certain
level of return,
if it were real,
everybody would do it.
Like you think about this --
when has there ever been a time
that somebody has been making
a lot of money off an investment
and they made commercials
about it?
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't work that way!
Nobody cares
that much about you!
[ Laughter ]
-You mean, once they're telling
me, that proves it's not real?
-That's all I'm saying.
When they are coming
to offer this to you like,
"Hey, guys, here's a way
that everybody can get rich,"
no one has ever
[ Laughter ]
positioned anything to tell us
how we all can get rich.
It doesn't go that way.
-Well, I still think
it's pretty good and I'm putting
all my money into it.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
-Hey, man, I appreciate it.
-I really appreciate it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Bomani Jones, everybody.
New episodes of "Game Theory"
premiere Friday nights
on HBO and HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with Sam Morrison.